le rejet des autres le repli sur soi
je crois que quand on s'est dit ça on
s'est tous dit vous savez
le
cigare alive bonjour il est 15h 15 nous
sommes en direct grande journée de
politique grand meeting cet après-midi
pour emmanuel macron j - 8 avant le
second tour le président candidat est à
marseille pour son unique meeting de
l'entre-deux-tours prise de parole
depuis le jardin du pharo regardez ces
images qui nous arrive le président doit
parler dans une quinzaine de minutes
nous vivons cela ensemble vous réagissez
évidemment sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube
on lit vos questions les transmet à nos
journalistes sur place au cadre de la
campagne des manuels matheron qui
viendront à notre micro et on en a un
avec nous c'est julien de normandie
julien de normandie je sais pas si
longtemps il est il est présent là bas
devant le
la scène julien de normandie on le voit
sur le côté est-ce qu'ils mentent en
monsieur de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture est ce que vous m'entendez
pour l'instant pas de pas de retour pas
de retour avec monsieur de normandie on
va essayer d'aller dans dans quelques
instants ce que je peux vous dire pour
le moment c'est que je vous présente le
contexte évidemment parce que marseille
ce n'est évidemment pas un choix un
choix anodin c'est le premier tour au
premier tour il voulait aller à
marseille le président de la république
il avait dû annuler son premier grand
meeting c'était au mois de mars le
président avait été rattrapé par le par
le contexte la guerre en ukraine
son entourage a répété qu'il voulait à
tout prix venir ici je vous propose
qu'on écoute un petit peu ce qui se
passe et puis on retrouve monsieur de
normandie dans un instant
public pour la première fois une classe
entièrement dédié aux enfants de moins
de 3 ans les 1000 premiers jours de vie
d'un citoyen français sont décision
nos générations ont aujourd'hui à
refonder notre europe pour faire face à
ces promesses de démocratie vivante le
progrès et de paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette cathédrale nous la rebâtir ont
toutes les entreprises toutes les
équipes qui sont pas mensualisés c'est
extraordinaire
aujourd'hui à saint martin et saint
barthélémy un plan national de
reconstruction sera déployée plus
rapidement possible
tous les pays doivent réhaussé leurs
engagements climatiques d'ici à la corde
la france tire sa révérence les soldats
français vont donc quitter le mali on
voulait aussi montrer ce matin ces
images inédites
les efforts et neuf appartements sur 12
étaient habitées
ici c'est marseille
pour de gilet jaune ici à mon corps je
peux rater
ce que je souhaite c'est que vous
puissiez vous exprimer de la manière
la plus directe j'ai tout mon temps
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république il autorise
le recours à la procréation médicalement
assistée pour toutes les femmes voilà
une timide emmanuel macron qui se
prépare prises de paroles d'ici à les 13
minutes il a prévu de parler une petite
heure à partir de 15h30 on est en direct
avec julien de normandie donc on la
retrouvait le ministre de l'agriculture
très impliqués dans cette campagne d'
emmanuel macron bonjour merci d'être
avec nous monsieur le ministre moment
important aujourd'hui on a peu vu une
réunion candidats avant le premier tour
on le voit beaucoup plus depuis depuis
dimanche dernier est-ce que cet après
midi il sera dans cette veine macron
partout macron proche des gens macron
populaire il veut faire un tour de force
cet après-midi
et bien son objectif cet après midi
c'est surtout de parler écologie de
parler environnement de parler en fait
d'un sujet qui concerne tout tous les
jeunes de notre pays absolument
toute notre société dans les actes du
quotidien et ce qui se joue c'est
vraiment un projet de société vous avez
face à emmanuel macron une candidate qui
est une candidate de l'extrême droite
qui tout simplement climato-sceptiques
et vous avez un inverse emmanuel macron
qui va détailler cet après midi un
projet ambitieux ambitieux pour notre
environnement ambitieux pour lutter
contre le changement climatique
ambitieux en finale pour notre avenir
pour notre jeunesse et je crois que
c'est très important
mais surtout vous avez une volonté une
envie une envie des français qui
viennent à la rencontre du candidat
emmanuel manque macron c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez énormément de
personnes autour de moi qui sont des
militants engagés et qui ont envie envie
de ce projet envie de porter ces valeurs
et puis vous avez aussi beaucoup de
français auprès desquels le candidat est
allé à la rencontre cette semaine qui
ont des interrogations des questions et
donc il fallait convaincre il faut
préciser les choses il faut montrer les
ambitions et ça va être encore une
nouvelle fois le cas cet après-midi sur
la question de l'environnement et du
climat
non vous savez vous avez aussi beaucoup
d'élus de gauche aujourd'hui aux côtés
du candidat emmanuel macron et quand
vous parlez de l'environnement quand
vous parlez du crime à vous parler juste
de l'avenir de notre société s'il ya
bien un sujet sur lequel il faut sortir
définitivement de ces clivages
droite-gauche de savoir d'où viennent
les personnes c'est bien sûr le sujet de
l'environnement de l'écologie ce qui se
joue c'est tout simplement l'avenir
l'avenir de nos enfants l'avenir de nos
sociétés
mais je le redis dimanche prochain
prochain c'est une forme de référendum
sur l'écologie qui se joue parce que
d'un côté vous avez une candidate de
l'extrême droite qui tout simplement
climato sceptiques songez qu'elle va
réduire les investissements pour lutter
contre le changement climatique
c'est du jamais vu dans toutes les
campagnes présidentielles que de réduire
ses financements et d'être à ce point
climato sceptiques al'inverse vous avez
un candidat emmanuel macron qui croient
à l'avenir qui appréhendent les projets
avec l'ensemble des difficultés et qui
veut se battre avec détermination pour
trouver des solutions des solutions face
au climat
c'est idiot
immatriculé morandière
parce que j'ai envie de dire
j'ai
été
alors je suis désolé si la connexion est
mauvais je n'ai pas du tout entendu la
question pardon
[Applaudissements]
ah non moi je pense que tout simplement
il ya une forme de lucidité
de beaucoup de nos concitoyens face à ce
que représente marine le pen telle
qu'elle l'a montré lors des derniers
jours de campagne que nous venons de
vivre son j'ai quand même que pendant la
dernière semaine que nous venons de
vivre marine le pen s'est tour à tour
prononcé en faveur du retour du retour
de la peine de mort elle s'est ensuite
prononcé en faveur du choix des
journalistes
elle s'est ensuite prononcé en faveur
d'une alliance militaire avec la russie
et cetera et cetera donc je pense tout
simplement
c'est aujourd'hui la clarté la clarté
des positions qui est exprimée qui ai vu
qui est considérée et je crois que le
vrai visage de marine le pen est à
nouveau mis en avant sur tous ces sujets
que je viens d'évoquer mais j'aurais pu
en évoquer d'autres
oui enfin regarder regarder précisément
regarder précisément cela parce que
c'est trop facile le mardi d'être pour
la peine de mort et le mercredi de dire
en fait je suis contre vous regardez ses
déclarations depuis 2015 elle a toujours
été très clair voyez elle fait
aujourd'hui des élections
présidentielles une forme de référendum
sur la peine de mort et ben moi je
préfère plutôt parler de la peine de
mort parler de l'avenir de notre pays
parler de l'avenir des jeunes parler de
l'avenir face au changement climatique
de créer cet espoir de créer cette
détermination fatigue face à des sujets
compliqués mais pas de remettre sur la
table des sujets tels que la peine de
mort que marine le pen soutient dernière
question julien de normandie d'un monde
sur les deux grands sujets de cet
entre-deux tours la question du voile et
la question des retraites est ce
qu'emmanuel macro va cet après-midi
clarifier sa position doit clarifier sa
position tout à l'heure à la tribune où
est-ce qu'ils préféreraient éviter ces
sujets se concentrait sur sur des thèmes
où il se sent plus à l'aise
mais il a des positions sur ces deux
sujets que ce soit sur la laïcité que ce
soit sur les retraites et la réforme des
retraites proposé des positions qui sont
très claires il a eu à de multiples
occasions
la possibilité de les exprimer de les
détailler donc ces positions sont très
claires à la différence encore une fois
de la candidate de l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui l'objectif est de parler
environnement climat avenir jeunesse
dans sept villes françaises marseille
qui est l'une des villes les plus jeunes
de notre pays l'une des villes
profondément concernés et impactés par
le changement climatique et donc c'est
ce discours sur l'écologie que le
candidat emmanuel macron prononcera cet
après-midi
litres de l'agriculture d'avoir été avec
nous c'est après merci à juste avant ce
meeting d'emmanuel macro emmanuel macron
qui devrait s'exprimer aller d'ici cinq
minutes vous réagissez toujours sur le
youtube sur lefigaro.fr également et je
prends vos questions je les transmets à
nos journalistes sur place on va on va
les rejoindre dans quelques instants je
remercie vincent roux seront derrière la
caméra qui a pu assurer ce duplex faut
quand même préciser et je vous le
précise que marseille est bien sonnés ce
n'est pas anodin il faut savoir
reconnaître les résultats du premier
tour a à marseille et bien c'est jean
luc mélenchon qui était arrivé en tête
assez largement plus de 31% des
suffrages avec une progression de six
points quand même par rapport à 2010 est
à 2017 et puis emmanuel macron est
arrivé lui en deuxième position lui
aussi la progresser il a doublé marine
le pen qui est arrivée elle seconde en
2010 est méprisant candidat est assez
loin devant luc mélenchon il a fait
22,60 2% des voix dans cette ville il y
a donc là un électorat à aller chercher
je lui on va essayer de retrouver si on
peut vincent redon dans un instant avec
nos autres journalistes du fils du roi
arthur berda notamment nez on me dit qu
emmanuel macron est en train d'arriver
et on va sûrement commencer à le voir le
président le président candidat avec
voilà le voit si il sort du palais du
pharo pour venir prendre prendre place à
la tribune pour son premier et unique
meeting d'entre deux tours emmanuel
macron qui est donc à marseille une
ville qui lui est cher lui le supporters
de l'om une vie la lettre dans laquelle
il n'avait pas pu se rendre lors du
premier tour empêché par le contexte de
la guerre en ukraine on va suivre ça on
nous annonce un discours d'une heure
d'une heure maximum on sait qu'il avait
mis beaucoup plus de temps à nanterre
lors de son de son premier de son
premier discours près de deux heures à
nanterre devant trente mille personnes
ce sera un petit peu resserré mais mais
l'équipe de campagne nous annonce qu'on
veut faire un peu différemment qu'on
veut faire un peu plus populaires
sanchez debout avec ce soleil a
marseille il fait 23 degrés ça chez eux
aujourd'hui sur sur la cité phocéenne
emmanuel macron qui est donc en train
d'arriver à la tribune vous réagissez
sur le youtube sur lefigaro.fr on
regarde tout ça et puis on des bri après
après le discours d' emmanuel macron on
débrief tout ça je suis toutes vos
interventions toutes vos questions on
analysera un discours qui est censé être
très tournée vers l'écologie c'est ce
que nous a dit pendant plusieurs minutes
julien de normandie emmanuel macron
monta monte à la tribune un dernier bain
de foule avant de prendre la parole on
vit ce moment on se retrouve tout à
l'heure sur le figaro live et on écoute
emmanuel macron
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci mes amis
merci d'être là à marseille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je sais que évidemment les
marseillaise et les marseillais sont là
mais de nice à toulon jusqu'à briançon
mais quatre coins de cette belle région
vous êtes venu aujourd'hui
pour être là et merci
[Musique]
de la montagne à la mer les quartiers de
la métropole au village vous êtes là
nous sommes là
bien dessiné
bien décidés dans une semaine à
l'emporter
[Applaudissements]
alors marseille vous l'avez montré
c'est cette magnifique ville de
méditerranée d'europe de surf et de
générosité
marseille
[Musique]
ville de jeunesse qui s'est faite à
travers le temps partant et tant de
destins mêlés je connais ici
levy d'italiens d'espagnols
d'arméniens de maghrébins de tentes et
en venant d'afrique des français
revenant d'algérie et restons ici auprès
de la méditerranée les chéris
c'est ça marseille
c'est la fraternité
au coeur de la république c'est un
laboratoire de la république et c'est
pourquoi comme je le rappelais un
instant c'est ici que nous avons voulu
bâtir avec marseille en grand le début
d'une nouvelle méthode
marseille
et nous nous tous
ensemble
pour faire réagir
alors si je suis ici devant vous c'est
parce qu'il ya
quelques jours
nos compatriotes
ont placé le projet que nous défendons
en tête du premier tour
[Applaudissements]
et ce projet est d'abord un projet de
force pour notre pays un projet pour
créer produire bâtir cette france de
2030 en faire une puissance créative
agricoles industrielles technologiques
nous permettre tous ensemble
de créer davantage d'emplois de trouver
davantage de solutions de faire qu'en
france on ne sombre pas dans la peur du
lendemain mais qu'on y construisent des
solutions pour demain cette france de
nos enfants c'est cela le projet que
nous portons
c'est un projet de simplification pour
que tant
d'initiatives porté à travers le
territoire que nos mères nos élus ici
présent que tant d'entrepreneurs
d'acteurs associatifs porte et qu'il
voudrait conduire plus vite c'est un
projet pour une france plus belle plus
forte dans une europe unie comme elle a
su l'être face à la pandémie comme elle
sait l'être elle saura l'être face à la
guerre qui revient en ukraine
c'est un projet pour l'égalité des
chances par l'école par la culture par
le sport c'est un projet qui croient
dans l'humain et qui veut permettre à
chacune et chacun d'exprimer la voix son
propre chemin
et je salue ici la présence de plusieurs
d'entre vous qui portait cette ambition
l'école
celle que nous avons commencé ici à
refonder avec marseille en grand
celle que nous voulons rebâtir par une
méthode nouvelle
la culture vous êtes temps à vous battre
de toulon à la criée de ramatuelle à
avignon contre les idées de l'extrême
contre l'extrême droite par l'ouverture
par l'intelligence par le beau
le sport
qui permet à chacun de construire sa
dignité sa force son projet dans cette
ville qui a connu le toit de l'europe
un jour de mai 93
et qui a encore montré qu ici on sait
faire des reprises de volée
merci dimitri
marseille qui sera l'une des grandes
villes de ces jeux olympiques de 2024 le
sport qui sera aussi par notre ambition
par notre ambition le moyen de permettre
à chaque jeune de
bâtir dans la république sa place
[Applaudissements]
oh
notre projet
notre projet c'est aussi un projet pour
la santé un projet pour tenter tant
d'ambitions qui de manière concrète veut
rebâtir cette égalité des chances sur le
terrain parce qu'il n'ya aucune fatalité
c'est un projet pour nos quartiers pour
lesquelles nous nous sommes battus ces
dernières années ensemble et pour
lesquels nous continuerons de nous
battre
[Applaudissements]
projet pour le quartier projets pour nos
ruralité projet pour tous les
territoires
parce que oui il n'ya qu'un projet qui
permet de réconcilier au lieu de diviser
celui qui investit dans l'humain celui
qui permet à des projets de naître de
bâtir de construire de la république de
demain celui qui permet de conjurer la
fatalité pour permettre à chacune et
chacun de vivre
celui qui redonne à chaque enfant de la
république sa dignité
sa place
[Musique]
et donc on vient de quel que soit le
quartier derrière moi là où il ya encore
aujourd'hui tant de séparation temps de
barrières
notre ambition depuis cinq ans mais elle
doit redoubler dans les années qui
viennent doit être de casser les murs
qui isole d'ouvrir les routes qui donne
des perspectives de bâtir une école qui
permet de libérer d'ouvrir l'accès à la
culture qui permet de vivre
[Applaudissements]
c'est cela
notre destin
car nous sommes pays d'ouverture
nous sommes fait deux millénaires
de millénaire
de migration de mouvement d'intégration
nous avons bâti civilisation une culture
une ouverture au monde une exigence et
une volonté de toujours porter cette
voix unique à l'égard du reste du monde
cette fierté française c'est cela ce
n'est pas le grand rabougrissement ce
n'est pas la grande division
ce n'est pas la grande séparation qui
consisterait à dire à des enfants nés
sur notre sol élevée dans notre
république qu'ils n'y ont plus leur
place et qui n'ont plus leurs droits
j'avais
[Musique]
par contre mes amis
si ce projet notre projet a été placé en
tête
le 10 avril comme vous je regarde notre
pays
lucide
je regarde ses divisions ses fractures
je vois les extrêmes
je vois les abstentions
et nous ne pouvons pas crier victoire
alors je suis là
et je continuerai à l'être croyez moi
[Applaudissements]
ah
mais les extrêmes se nourrissent de quoi
les abstentionnistes se nourrissent de
quoi
des peurs
des doutes
parfois de nos échecs aussi je suis
lucide
du fait que nous avons parfois promis et
que la vie n'a pas changé assez vite
alors je suis devant vous avec
encore plus d'énergie qu'il ya cinq ans
avant avec encore plus d'envié de faire
[Applaudissements]
mais en sachant fermement que chaque
minute que nous perdrons c'est une
minute que nous leur donnerons
alors oui
nous ne devons pas simplement gagner le
24 avril
nous devons redoubler d'énergie pour
faire réussir
redoubler d'énergie pour réussir là où
parfois nous avons échoué là où nous
avons été trop lentement là où nous
avons tâtonné mais en étant lucide
alors cette ambition
cette ambition que je veux porter avec
vous ça n'est pas je vais vous le dire
en toute sincérité
comme vous le crier parfois avec un
enthousiasme qui me touche
je vais vous avouer quelque chose
je n'ai aucune envie de faire cinq ans
de plus
non je ne veux pas les faire en plus
je veux complètement refonder je veux
que ce soit cinq années de
renouvellement complet
ce qui se joue le 24 avril ce qui se
jouera derrière ne doit pas être une
reconduction qu'une continuation mais
bien une réinvention une nouvelle
ambition
[Applaudissements]
et les ruptures que nous avons su
incarner les ruptures que nous avons su
faire il ya cinq ans et durant ces
années nous devons les continuer nous ne
sommes pas le camp du système jamais
nous devons encore inventé nous battre
recent days et bâtir l'ambition qui
permettra de répondre à toutes ses
colères assez peur à ces voix qui se
taisent c'est cela que lambie l'ambition
que je nourris avec vous
[Applaudissements]
à
et si nous voulons aller au bout d'un
projet d'innovation
d'indépendance de prospérité d'inclusion
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
d'écologie et je vais y revenir nous
devons en profondeur encore et encore
savoir marquer des ruptures des
ambitions nouvelles revenir là où nous
avons échoué pour recommencer et
réinventer cela doit être cela notre
ambition est avec une ambition aussi de
méthodes complètement nouvelle le avec
vous n'est pas simplement un slogan à
mes yeux
ce que nous avons commencé ici à
marseille
c'est aussi cette volonté 2
de dire à nos compatriotes que nous
avons entendu leur voix
elle n'est pas simplement de 6 de
s'exprimer lors d'élections ou de
demander des élections pour le pass vial
et c'est aussi de leur dire que
manifester dès le lendemain contre le
résultat d'une élection démocratique ne
mène à rien
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est réinventer ensemble
l'action en démocratie
c'est de considérer que chacune et
chacun
veut faire que pour réinventer notre
école il faut la bâtir avec toutes les
parties prenantes
élus parents enseignants élèves que pour
rebâtir notre santé il faut la
réinventer avec toutes les parties
prenantes
médecins soignants élus patients
cette chance ce changement de méthode
profond c'est celui que nous adopterons
dans les cinq ans qui viennent si les
françaises et les français vous
accordent leur confiance
[Applaudissements]
alors ici à marseille
j'aurais pu vous parler du danger que
représente l'extrême droite pour notre
pays
vous le connaissez ce danger
de marseille à toulon jusqu'au fin fond
de la région à plusieurs reprises vous
êtes nombreux à vous êtes battus contre
les extrêmes et à chaque fois avoir
gagné
[Applaudissements]
alors j'aurais pu vous parler des
risques que l'extrême droite fait peser
sur nos libertés sur la liberté de la
presse lorsqu'elle prétend décider qui
est journaliste et qui ne l'est pas sur
la liberté ne sifflait pas l'extrême
droite ne suffit pas l'extrême droite
bat et là le 24 avril
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu vous parler des coûts que
l'extrême droite entend porter à
l'égalité
à l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes
lorsqu'elle évoque l'avortement de
confort
l'égalité entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres lorsqu'elle propose aux
plus riches rentiers lorsqu'ils ont
moins de 30 ans de les exonérer
totalement d'impôts
ce que j'entendais tout à l'heure me
dire on est là je suis là aussi je les
rassure devrait plutôt aller manifester
contre ce projet
choisissez vos ennemis
le confondez pas tout
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais plus à marseille vous parlez de
la rupture que l'extrême droite prépare
avec la fraternité républicaine
lorsqu'elle veut mettre en cause le
droit d'asile
organiser un référendum pour rétablir la
peine de mort
[Musique]
battez les le 24 avril
[Applaudissements]
dans la rupture qu'elle prépare avec
notre laïcité
lorsqu'elle veut stigmatiser des
millions de français interdire le port
du voile ou là mais rupture casher ou
halal
alors battez les
j'aurais plus ici vous parler du projet
de sortie de l'europe que l'extrême
droite défend lorsqu'elle propose le
divorce entre l'allemagne et la france
la sortie du conseil de l'europe une
alliance militaire avec la russie et pas
un mot pas un mot pour le continent
africain de l'autre côté de cette mère
alors battez les le 24 avril
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu aussi vous parler du rapport
quelque peu distant que madame le pen
comme monsieur zemmour entretiennent
avec la science eux qui auraient voulu
vous administrez de la chloroquine et du
vaccin russe
ne sifflait pas ça n'est pas devenu et
je le rassure ça ne viendra pas à ce que
le 24 avril nous voterons
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu vous parler de tout cela de
bien d'autres choses encore mais ici à
marseille je suis venu vous parler très
directement
ici je suis venu avec vous pour aller
droit au but
[Applaudissements]
est allé droit au but c'est vous dire
que
[Musique]
nous avons entendu deux messages
le premier c'est celui qu'une bonne
partie de nos compatriotes et je sais
que vous le portez aussi nous ont fait
entendre le 10 avril dernier dans les
urnes
un message fort pour mettre
l'environnement au coeur de notre
campagne et des années à venir pour la
france
le deuxième message
que nous avons entendu
c'est celui des plus grands
scientifiques du monde entier il y a
deux semaines
une fois encore mais plus grave encore
le giec le groupement international
d'experts pour le climat a remis un
rapport qui nous donne trois en trois
ans pour tenir les objectifs des accords
de paris contre le réchauffement
climatique et léguer à nos enfants une
planète
vivable
[Musique]
et donc oui
c'est à nous d'agir et c'est à nous de
faire
et ce message
écologique du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle française
ce message une fois encore des plus
grands scientifiques
ce message que notre jeunesse depuis
plusieurs mois prône portes de marche en
marche et de mobilisation en
mobilisation
nous devons aujourd'hui
savoir lui donner une perspective
nouvelle pour le 24 avril et pour les
années qui viennent
alors nous savons nous ici les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
dans les vallée de la tinée de la
vésubie de la roya cher christian pierre
frédéric chez renault nous l'avons vu
nous l'avons vécu
dans les outre mer des sargasses aux
ouragans nous en connaissons les
conséquences
du gel qui touche nos agriculteurs
encore cette année
nous en savons
tous les méfaits et donc oui ce
dérèglement climatique nous touche nous
tous aujourd'hui déjà
nous n'avons plus à attendre et nous ne
pouvons plus attendre nous le savons
alors nous n'avons pas rien fait durant
ces cinq années comme parfois j'entends
certains le résumé avec caricature
c'est sûr je vous le confesse c'est
toujours plus difficile
de promettre d'engager de relance et
lorsque on a cinq ans de responsabilités
mais je veux simplement en quelques mots
ici dire ce que nous avons fait tous
ensemble
les gouvernements successifs
les élus de terrain l'ensemble des
institutions les entreprises les
associations les agriculteurs les
citoyens parce que pendant cinq ans nous
avons fait pendant cinq ans qui viennent
de s'écouler
nous sommes battus et d'abord nous avons
pris des décisions qui avait été tant de
fois reportée
pour lesquelles certains qui aujourd'hui
nous combattre sans esprit de
distinction en voulant confondre
l'extrême droite avec nous mêmes
ils oublient ils oublient ce que nous
avons fait notre dame des landes contre
lesquels ils se sont tant battus le
projet europa city
au nord de paris la montagne d'or en
guyane le terminal 4 de l'aéroport de
roissy
tous ces projets qui les a arrêtés parce
qu'il n'était pas écologique parce que
c'était du gigantisme qui ne
correspondait plus un modèle viable
c'est nous
[Applaudissements]
et pour prendre ses décisions
il fallait simplement pas simplement
manifester protester contre celles et
ceux qui sont aux responsabilités mais
il fallait en responsabilité
allez voir des élus
des salariés
des citoyens et leur dire pour le bien
de l'environnement nous ne le ferons pas
j'ai rarement vu les militants les plus
férus ces jours-là être à nos côtés
mais nous l'avons fait
nous avons été parmi les premières
nations a fermé nos centrales à charbon
à mettre fin au permis d'hydrocarbures
nous avons décidé la fin de
l'exploitation d'hydrocarbures à 2040
mais quand il a fallu
à lux aller expliqué
dans nos zones sur notre sol en guyane
qu'on ne serait pas de nouveaux projets
là où il y avait des potentialités pour
faire
il a fallu expliquer là aussi à des élus
et des citoyens des entreprises nous
allons vous compensez mais nous ne
ferons pas pour l'écologie nous l'avons
fait
[Applaudissements]
nous avons accompagné 1 millions de
françaises et de français pour changer
leur vieille voiture et prendre hybride
une électrique ou un modèle de dernière
génération 1 millions de françaises et
de français pour rénover leur logement
et réduire leurs factures de chauffage
nous avons ensemble
avec les élus
construit treize mille kilomètres de
pistes cyclables
réinventer des lignes ferroviaires qui
était en train de fermer
[Musique]
ré ouvert des lignes de chemin de fer de
nuit qui permettent d'éviter le
transport en avion
hier joël
9000 kilomètres de petites lignes c'est
à dire des transports
écologiques nous avons avec nos
agriculteurs commencé à transformer
notre agriculture nous avons doublé les
surfaces d'agriculture biologique et
nous sommes aujourd'hui nous france est
le premier pays d'europe en surface bio
le premier
oui monsieur le ministre
nous avons multiplié par vingt les
surfaces en haute qualité
environnementale nous nous sommes
engagés à diviser par deux le rythme de
l'artificialisation des sols et pour
cela donner les moyens à nos mères aux
départements et aux régions
d'investir pour justement reconvertir
leur friches industrielles
agricoles ou d'emprise public
nous avons créé dans notre droit grâce à
la convention citoyenne sur le climat
un des leades écocide pour ceux qui
intentionnellement se rendent coupables
de graves atteintes à l'environnement
[Applaudissements]
et je pourrais citer
des aires protégées à tant d'autres
combats tout ce que nous avons durant
ces cinq dernières années conduit sur ce
sujet mais la bataille
nous l'avons aussi mené à
l'international
rappelez vous
quand en juin 2017 les etats unis
d'amérique ont décidé de quitter les
accords de paris ces accords tout le
monde nous le disait été condamné
on nous disait c'est fichu c'est fini
nous nous sommes levés
et là où la france en 2015 avait su
grâce à sa diplomatie
bâtir ces accords nous avons résisté
nous avons convoqué le monde one planet
ce mythe le 12 décembre 2017
nous avons gardé
l'europe la chine
les autres états du monde ensemble nous
avons réengager les entreprises les
associations
nous avons permis que la russie et la
turquie
ratifient ces accords
et enfin que les états unis décident de
revenir ces accords sont bien là et nous
avons gagné
nous ne sommes battus 2 one planet en
one au chien de sommeil d'europe aux
états unis en passant par l'afrique pour
la biodiversité et lancer un agenda
nouveau
pour la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et pour lancer un véritable
agenda européen
oui au printemps 2010 8 nous n'étions
que huit états membres à nous battre sur
ce sujet nous avons obtenu l'accord de
tous au mois de décembre dernier pour
construire un accord européen sur le
climat et porter la neutralité carbone
en 2050
[Applaudissements]
et du monde à l'elysée nous l'avons fait
car à l'elysée plus modestement
mais l'exemplarité serre nous avons
innové en compensant l'empreinte carbone
de tous les déplacements et il y en a
parfois pour un président en
construisant une crèche qui est le
premier bâtiment public entièrement
conçu avec des matériaux biosourcés oui
nous nous sommes battus durant ces cinq
années en prenant des décisions
difficiles et on les assume en mai en
actant que la bataille pour le climat
n'est pas simplement une question de
mobilisation
est encore moins une question
d'injonction n'est jamais une question
d'opposition de bloc à bloc
mais cette la craie d'une réussite
commune d'un investissement de la nation
d'un accompagnement de chacune et chacun
pour changer les habitudes
c'est cela ce que nous avons fait
pour réussir la bataille pour le climat
pas d'injonctions mais du respect de
l'ambition pas de fausse leçons
mais la carte est dans les objectifs et
de l'investissement alors tous ces
efforts ont des résultats
et je les défends nous avons été deux
fois plus vite que durant les deux
quinquennats qui précédait pour réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
nous avons protéger la biodiversité
davantage et nous avons diminué de 12%
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
cinq ans
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est pour dire
que l'inaction pas chez moi
[Applaudissements]
mais très clairement ce que le giec nous
a encore dit c'est que ça ne suffit pas
et si nous voulons respecter les accords
de paris
il faut aller deux fois plus vite que ce
que nous venons de faire ensemble durant
ces cinq années deux fois plus vite donc
vous savez quoi on va le faire
[Applaudissements]
alors j'entends
l'anxiété qui existe chez beaucoup de
nos jeunes je suis frappé dans temps de
déplacement quand je vais au contact je
pense que vous le vivez comme moi de
voir notre jeunesse nos adolescents
parfois les enfants
avoir peur de l'avenir de la planète
en parler avec angoisse me dire mais
quelle vie j'aurai est-ce que même
j'aurais une vie possible
face à ce qu on appelle cet éco anxiété
nous devons réussir dans les mois et les
années qui viennent à convertir cette
anxiété en ambition et en actions c'est
cela notre défi
parce que de l'autre côté
j'entends l'anxiété de françaises et de
français sincère
qui me disent mais moi je vois comme un
mur devant moi envie qu'il faut tout
changer que je ne pourrais pas continuer
mon activité on essayait de me
culpabiliser de me dire que mon mode de
vie
que ce que je fais chaque jour ce que
mes parents faisait au chant ou à
l'usiné mal parce que je suis dans une
industrie qui polluent ou parce que le
modèle qui est le nôtre a fait que j'ai
dû utiliser tel ou tel produit
et il ya aussi une anxiété aussi sincère
de beaucoup de nos compatriotes
face à ce qui leur semble comme un
changement impossible trop dur trop
rapide et cette anxiété
c'est celle que l'extrême droite va
chercher lorsqu'elle des avec nous
je cite la candidate d'extrême droite
plus de terrorisme climatique dit l
employé un tel terme avec nous
fini les éoliennes nous allons les
démonter
bon courage
bonne utilisation de l'argent du
contribuable
avec nous lors dit elle
avec nous l'an vittel
la neutralité carbone 2050 d'ailleurs la
place tels en 2030 elle qui connaît si
bien ces chiffres
finissent neutralité carbone même
incompétente et les climato sceptiques
[Applaudissements]
mais donc vous le voyez bien ne pouvons
pas laisser ces deux ans y étaient face
à face
nos plus jeunes et celles et ceux qui
sont anxieux pensant que la planète ne
sera plus viable et l'anxiété de celles
et ceux qui craignent un changement trop
rapide nous devons réconcilier tout le
pays
par un changement de paradigme par une
ambition nouvelle et ce changement de
paradigme
mais pas simplement d'aller un peu plus
vite de continuer ce que nous avons fait
c'est d'aller deux fois plus vite et de
transformer la politique l'économie les
paysages et nos vies dans la france pour
les cinq ans qui viennent c'est ce
changement de paradigme que je veux pour
nous
[Applaudissements]
moi aussi
alors
la politique que je mènerai dans les
cinq ans à venir
sera donc écologique ou ne sera pas
et donc
pour placer l'écologie au coeur du
nouveau paradigme politique
comme au 19ème siècle
ou face aux défis éducatifs
jules ferry
était à la fois président du conseil et
ministre de l'instruction publique
mon prochain premier ministre sera
directement chargé de la planification
écologique
[Applaudissements]
parce que cela concerne tous les
domaines tous les secteurs toutes les
dépenses tous les équipements tous les
investissements bref toutes les
politiques
ça n'est pas simplement une politique
c'est la politique des politiques
et parce que cela démontre
irréfutablement
l'importance que nous accorderons à ce
combat du siècle
le premier ministre
sera pour agir
appuyé par deux ministres forts
le ministre de la planification
énergétique
et
je rassure ici chacune et chacun
le ministre étant une fonction il peut
s'agir d'une femme ou d'un homme
comme la ministre actuelle le monde
et donc le ministre de la planification
énergétique
aura pour mission de faire de la france
la première grande nation à sortir du
gaz du pétrole et du charbon c'est
possible et nous le sommes
[Applaudissements]
et pour cela il faudra d'abord planifier
une stratégie de sobriété énergétique
car l'énergie qui polluent le moins est
celle qu'on ne consomme pas
il lui reviendra de développer les
énergies renouvelables
en multipliant par dix la puissance
solaire installé
des grands projets jusqu'au projet de
micro solaire quant aux ruralité
[Applaudissements]
en engageant le déploiement de 50 parc
éolien offshore d'ici 2050 40 gigawatts
nouveau
il y reviendra également d'engager la
construction de ces nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires
pourquoi
car c'est la seule énergie qui ne
produisent pas de gaz à effet de serre
et qui ne dépendent pas de la météo
et donc partout dans le monde mais comme
on met beaucoup de même quand on met
beaucoup de panneaux solaires et
d'éoliennes à chaque fois on le complète
avec d'autres sources d'énergie non
intermittente et je vais être très clair
avec vous entre le charbon et le gaz
d'un côté et le nucléaire de l'autre je
choisis le nucléaire
[Applaudissements]
et le ministre de la planification
énergétique
aura à bâtir une stratégie hydrogène car
c'est aussi par l'hydrogène pour nos
avions nos trains nos bateaux que nous
voyons ici nos bus
nos industries par les changements
d'usagé que nous pourrons avoir des
modes de déplacement et de production
plus écologique car l'hydrogène
pourra se substituer progressivement au
gaz naturel
l'hydrogène est produit par l'électro
lise
pour ça il faut de l'électricité c'est
pour cette raison entre autres qu'il
nous faudra dans notre pays produire
plus d'électricité non carbonées par le
renouvelable et par le nucléaire mais
cet hydrogène sans carbone c'est celui
qui nous permettra de nous passer du
fioul
du gaz naturel
au fond des énergies fossiles
[Applaudissements]
l'autre ministre sera chargé de la
planification écologique territoriale
et aura pour mission d'organiser avec
les élus locaux la transition
environnementale
dans chaque territoire dans nos régions
nos départements de métropole mais jusqu
à l'échelle du canton avec un principe
simple
l'agenda écologique
est un agenda de confiance il faut
travailler avec nos élus locaux et ce
sera un agenda de décentralisation
massive
[Applaudissements]
partout
et donc avec les territoires
il développera des moyens de se déplacer
en train en vélo en voiture électrique
pour tous avec ce projet de voiture à
moins de voitures électriques à moins de
100 euros par mois nous mettrons en
place davantage de transports en commun
comme c'est rer métropolitain auquel on
tient tant ici à marseille et dans la
métropole
donc cette planification territoriale
oui elle permettra de changer les moyens
de nous déplacer au quotidien transports
publics transport individuel mais aussi
pour nos grands industriels en
développant de nouveaux stratégie pour
le fret ferroviaire et le fluvial
comment développer un port comme le port
de marseille sans avoir une stratégie
complètement nouvelle avec le
ferroviaire et le fluvial et sans
permettre de sortir toutes les
marchandises autrement que par les
camions mais bien
par le fleuve les fleuves jusqu'à lyon
et au delà et le chemin de fer
est donc
cette stratégie vous le voyez est une
stratégie de réinvention de me
territoire de réaménagement de nos
territoires de manière collective comme
nous ne l'avons pas fait depuis
freyssinet dans notre pays à ce point où
l'on va à nouveau
construire des canaux
réinvestir sur le fluvial le fret
ferroviaire pour pouvoir libérer nos
routes nous passer des camions et donc
faire de l'écologie en continuant de
produire
c'est avec les territoires
que ce ministre pour accélérer la
rénovation des logements et des
bâtiments est organisée au moins la
rénovation thermique de 700 mille
logements par an sur les cinq ans qui
viennent
il leur reviendra ensemble d'agir pour
la qualité de l'eau la qualité de l'air
la qualité de l'alimentation car oui cet
agenda est un agenda de la qualité de la
vie et du mieux vivre
et c'est une planification que nous
ferons avec les territoires pour changer
la vie très concrètement
imaginez quand je parle de qualité de
l'air
que la pollution de l'air cause chaque
année 50 mille décès parfois des enfants
ces quinze fois les décès liés aux
accidents de la route
alors nous savons ce que notre pays a su
faire lorsqu'il s'est mobilisée contre
les victimes de la route engageant avec
la même force une politique pour faire
baisser les victimes de la pollution de
l'air
partout en france
alors j'annonce que si les français me
font confiance à nouveau
[Applaudissements]
nous lancerons immédiatement
un effort massif de purification de
l'air dans nos écoles nos hôpitaux nos
maisons de retraite et dans tous les
bâtiments publics
et vous en verrez
les premiers résultats avant la fin de
cette année
et il en sera de même sur la qualité de
notre alimentation
nos paysans son temps déjà mais dans nos
écoles je veux qu'on aille encore plus
loin pour davantage de produits locaux
de circuits courts de produits bio et
grâce au plan alimentaire territoriaux
que nous avons bâtie par tous avec nos
départements nous permettront à chaque
fois dans la restauration collective et
en particulier pour nos enfants dans les
cantines
d'avoir une alimentation de qualité
et pour accompagner
et pour accompagner partout sur le
territoire nos compatriotes afin qu'ils
puissent se nourrir avec les meilleurs
produits possibles nous ferons les
efforts évidemment pour améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs
mais lutter contre la précarité
alimentaire avec entre autres le chèque
alimentaire
la politique sera écologique donc et
l'économie sera écologique également ou
ne sera pas
je vais être très clair avec vous
je ne crois pas dans la décroissance au
contraire
[Musique]
et je ne crois pas que se battre pour le
climat 4 sincère pour le climat et pour
la biodiversité
puisse
en quelque sorte la voir qu'une seule
solution ce serait de détruire telle ou
telle activité demandez à des
agriculteurs d'arrêter ou à des
industriels de faire mais je pense
qu'une telle politique n'est pas
possible dans notre pays pour une raison
simple c'est que pour financer notre
modèle social qui a été si fort pendant
la pandémie avec le quoi qu'il en coûte
pour financer nos écoles et nos hôpitaux
il nous faut produire et travailler
davantage
et donc oui
notre défi est de faire une économie
plus écologique pas moins d'économies
pour l'écologie
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi nous aurons un projet
unique sans précédent celui de france
2030 pour bâtir cette économie
décarbonée par l'innovation
les avions sans émission zéro carbone
les trains hydrogène la voiture
électrique produite en france les
éoliennes en mer produite en france
les mini réacteurs
et tant et tant d'autres solutions la
région il participera
d'avignon
à nice sophia antipolis en passant par
marseille toulon vous avez tant
tant de sites d'innovation unique
c'est par l'innovation
le numérique que nous bâtirons aussi ses
solutions pour avoir une économie qui
ira vers la neutralité carbone en 2050
mais pour en même temps créer des
emplois sur notre sol des filières
industrielles de l'activité dans nos
ports et ailleurs
c'est pourquoi
nous investirons aussi pour décarbonés
nos cimenterie nous à cirer nous le
savons ici à marseille à fos au combien
je le dis à toutes celles et ceux qui
travaillent
l'écologie ce n'est pas fermé vos
emplois fermer vos usines
c'est permettre de changer
des habitudes et des pratiques
remplacer
les vieilles chaudières avec lesquels on
conduisait l'activité
par le gaz ou le charbon en les
remplaçant par l'hydrogène
c'est par l'innovation vous permettent
de produire davantage mais le faire de
manière écologique et il n'y a pas de
fatalité
il n'y a pas de fatalité ça n'est là
aussi qu'une question d'investissements
et de volonté c'est pourquoi aussi nous
nous appuierons sur les chefs
d'entreprise je sais qu'il ya ici
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs et j'en connais
de longue date engagé sur la question
écologique
entrepreneurs du livre et de la culture
entrepreneurs du numérique industrielle
qui sont de grands entrepreneurs
écologique et écologistes je connais
tant d'associations engagées aussi sur
ceux sur cette question et pour le
climat
alors nous appuyer encore davantage sur
eux s'est changé en france et en europe
aussi les règles les parts variables des
dirigeants
seront à la fois
encadré dans leur nom tant au niveau
européen mais aussi soumis à l'atteinte
des objectifs environnementaux
[Applaudissements]
les grands dirigeants du 21ème siècle ne
sont pas simplement ceux et celles qui
ont de la performance économique ou
financière mais celles et ceux qui
seront à voir des résultats pour
l'inclusivité
pour l'égalité femmes hommes et pour la
question écologique oui les grands
patrons seront des patrons vers des
patrons éco-responsable
[Applaudissements]
avoir une économie plus écologique
s'est aussi accompagnée accélérer les
changements d'usagé nous avons commencé
de le faire ensemble en mettant fin en
nous battant contre eux
le gaspillage alimentaire en prenant de
nouvelles lois en nous battant justement
contre aussi le gaspillage des produits
manufacturés en luttant contre
l'obsolescence programmée
en luttant contre le plastique à usage
unique
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début de l'année les fruits et
légumes sont vendus en vrac plus dans
les sachets plastiques c'est le fruit de
nos lois
[Applaudissements]
et nous réduirons drastiquement dans les
cinq années qui viennent et nous
tiendrons mêmes accélérons le cap de
2040 pour sortir complètement des
plastiques non recyclables
mais quelle est la clé derrière cela une
méthode là aussi
qui permet de réconcilier l'écologie et
l'économie
un cap
avec un interdit à horizon et des
investissements des investissements
et la volonté de développer toute une
économie circulaire c'est à dire des
emplois des entreprises qui vont nous
permettre d'utiliser ce plastique
pour l'utiliser différemment et
construire de nouveaux matériaux au
moment où je vous parle aujourd'hui en
france grâce à nos ambitions écologiques
et notre politique économique nous avons
il y a quelques jours actes et de
l'ouverture
de la plus grande entreprise européenne
d'économie circulaire pour transformer
les plastiques y compris les plus
complexes
[Applaudissements]
et c'est le fruit de notre politique
d'attractivité
d'ambition économique écologique je vous
rassure
avec madame le pen fini car elle n'est
ni pour l'attractivité des
investissements étrangers mais pour
l'écologie l'a sifflé pas battre et
l'inde 24 avril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et cette transformation économique elle
est évidemment aussi européenne c'est
pourquoi nous nous battons pour que
notre agenda commercial soit aussi un
agenda climatique c'est pour cela que
nous sommes nous nous sommes posés au
mercosur car il ne reste ne respectent
pas nos objectifs ni des accords de
paris ni en matière de biodiversité
c'est pour cela que nous nous battrons
avec la présidence française pour
obtenir cette taxe carbone aux
frontières
qui permettra d'éviter la concurrence
déloyale pour nos industriels et nos
agriculteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sinon comment expliquer à une usine
qu'elle doit investir pour changer si on
permet d'importer des matériaux venant
du bout du monde qui n'ont pas fait les
mêmes efforts c'est pour cela que nous
nous battrons partout pour ceux qu'on
appelle les clauses miroir c'est à dire
demander la même chose aux autres que ce
que nous faisons en européen
et c'est à ce titre
que nous nous battrons partout pour les
clauses miroir qui permettent de lutter
contre la déforestation importé de
produire en france et en europe du soja
au lieu d'importer un soja du brésil
fait contre la forêt et la biodiversité
[Applaudissements]
et donc oui il y à bien un projet qui
permet de bâtir une économie écologique
favorables à la biodiversité protectrice
du climat
si nous avons ces solutions cet
investissement ces innovations cette
ambition européenne ce projet là c'est
le nôtre et nous le portons
[Applaudissements]
ce changement de paradigme
c'est celui que je veux aussi pour nos
paysages
les paysages qui m'entourent les nôtres
les vôtres oui si nous voulons nous
battre contre le dérèglement climatique
et pour la biodiversité
il nous faut savoir protéger nos
écosystèmes
la faune et la flore la nature
il nous faut nous battre pour nos
paysages et la vie qui s'y trouvent
alors pour cela j'irai au bout de cette
ambition dont nous n'avons dont nous
avons posé les bases durant ce
quinquennat
30 % d'air maritime et terrestre
protéger nous le feu
[Applaudissements]
car n'oubliez jamais que la france est
tout à la fois la deuxième puissance
maritime du monde grâce à nos îles je
pense à la corse à quelques encablures
d'ici et certains sont là
et notre méditerranée grâce à nos océans
et grâce à nous outre-mer
la réunion est là la polynésie je
l'entends
les antilles et la guyane tous les
océans tous les océans sont aussi
français
et nous sommes une immense puissance
forestière
la france à l'une des plus grandes
forêts d'europe mais la france est aussi
une puissance amazonienne
trésor tout à la fois de biodiversité
et de peuples autochtones
c'est cela la france n'en déplaise à
celles et ceux qui voulaient la réduire
[Applaudissements]
la france c'est ce littoral protégé par
notre conservatoire auquel nous tenons
tant par nos parcs que nous continuons
de classe et qu'il s'agisse de l'état
des régions comme des communes des
calanques que nous protégeons de nos
montagnes
de nos montagnes que le protégeant aussi
avec à chaque fois le même objectif
et c'est cela ce que je veux poursuivre
permettre de protéger la naturalité la
plus stricte lorsque nous devons
reconstituer la biodiversité
permettre à ces endroits de continuer et
poursuivre la recherche le travail des
scientifiques
relancer ce qu'il y avait parfois été
arrêté comme l'exploration des grands
fonds marins pour notre mère comment
expliquer que nous n'irions pas à
quelques encablures d'ici
plongé au fond du fond de la mer que
nous voudrions aller sur mars
c'est protéger
le largement en ayant des activités
compatibles car on le peut aussi c'est
permettre de protéger la montagne en
permettant à nos agriculteurs à une vie
économique de 6 bâtir harmonieusement
ces permettent de protéger nos mères en
permettant une pêche durable
sur nos zones
c'est permettre de protéger
en éduquant
et c'est pour cela que ce que je veux
aussi dans nos paysages poursuivre c'est
ce travail de changement culturel de
paradigme que beaucoup de communes ici
ont commencé de faire avec les acteurs
que j'évoquais mais en faire des espaces
où l'on apprend de césaire marine
éducative que les polynésiens nous ont
légué et que nous voulons essaimé
jusqu'au projet odysséo que nous que
nous développerons juste derrière moi
apprendre partager
avec nos enfants aient montré que le
projet écologique est aussi un projet de
la préservation du bo
des espèces
de l'éducation et de l'apprentissage
c'est tout cela
c'est aussi pour cela
que nous renforcerons les moyens que
nous mettrons pour protéger tous ses
espaces
protéger nos mères
partout et en particulier les protéger
contre eux la pêche illicite et la
prédation grâce à notre marine nationale
à laquelle je veux rendre hommage à
celle qui joue ici à marseille un rôle
si important
[Applaudissements]
le marin marseille ont protégé
accompagné tester les eaux tout fait
mais nos marins partout dans le monde
protègent nos zoo contre les prédateurs
la pêche illicite et clandestine et
celles et ceux qui viennent nous menacer
c'est pour ça aussi que nous
continuerons d'investir dans nos projets
dans nos forêts avec en particulier
cette volonté que j'ai d'ici 2030 de
plantes et 140 millions d'arbres pour la
france
ce grand plan c'est celui qui portera
notre ambition forestière planté
protéger développer une filière mais
assumer aussi de protéger
dans certains espaces une forêt libre
pour qu'elle puisse se régénérer en
particulier quand elle est un trésor de
biodiversité comme nous le faisons aussi
à l'international pour protéger la forêt
amazonienne où la forêt primaire au
coeur de l'afrique ses ambitions
françaises nous les poursuivons vous les
axes héros
et c'est aussi pour cela
que nous nous battrons partout contre
les décharges parler de la mer parler de
la forêt parler de la beauté de nos
paysages de la biodiversité
c'est reconnaître que nous avons
dans nos paysages depuis tenté tant
d'années
la trace visible sensible parfois les
plaies
de ceux qui ne va plus dans notre modèle
ces décharges à ciel ouvert qui polluent
nos paysages ces décharges qui se
déversent dans les rivières ou dans les
mers
lutter contre ce continent de plastique
qui étouffe la biodiversité en mer et
qu'ils nous menacent
ça n'est pas lutter contre le plastique
qui est déjà en mer car c'est déjà trop
tard plusieurs qui sont ici me l'ont
bien expliqué en septembre dernier le
plastique une fois en mer se dissout
en microparticules
ltu
algues plancton déjà
lutter contre la pollution par le
plastique
et les drames qu'il crée c'est lutter
contre le plastique qui arrivent dans
nos paysages dans nos décharges et nos
rivières pour cela il faut faire deux
choses en finir avec le plastique à
usage unique que l'on jette et mener la
stratégie que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
celle de l'économie circulaire celle du
tri sélectif celle que nous
intensifierons intensifieront par nos
investissements et les changements du
talent
mais il nous faut aussi en même temps
comme certains diraient
il nous faut en même temps en finir avec
ces grandes décharges c'est pourquoi sur
les trois ans qui viennent nous mettrons
fin
à cinquante grandes décharges à ciel
ouvert qui aujourd'hui polluent nos
territoires nos rivières et nos mers
menace notre biodiversité
et prépare ce plastique de demain qui
arrivera sinon dans notre mère
c'est tout cela lutter pour la
biodiversité pour nos forêts nos mères
nos paysages
[Applaudissements]
c'est possible bien sûr
enfin mes amis
nos vies seront écologiques ou ne seront
pas
oui
parce que l'écologie n'est pas seulement
la question de la politique
de l'économie de certains paysages
chacun prendra sa part dans ce combat du
siècle
chacun devra prendre sa part dans cet
avenir en commun que nous avons à
construire
nos enfants
d'abord
nous avons
nous avons déjà installé
250000 éco délégués qui dans nos écoles
construisent des actions de
sensibilisation formidable
nous irons plus loin en mettant en
oeuvre l'éducation au développement
durable pour tous depuis la maternelle
jusqu'au lycée
et comme le ministre
pardon comme le professeur joël l'a
proposé à la ministre
tous nos étudiants seront sensibilisés
aux enjeux environnementaux et
alimentaires dorénavant
les élus auront à prendre leur part en
déclinant les objectifs nationaux dans
leur commune leur département leur
région en bâtissant des solutions avec
des compétences nouvelles et des
investissements nouveaux nos artisans
auront leur part -qui rénoverons dans
les cinq ans à venir
trois millions et demi de logements au
moins pour y installer des fenêtres des
pompes à chaleur une meilleure isolation
et je ne parle pas du chantier colossal
des bâtiments publics du développement
des matériaux bio sur biosourcés d'une
vraie transformation pour tenter tant de
secteurs économiques
[Applaudissements]
nos paysans ils prendront leur part nos
agriculteurs ont déjà tant fait ces
dernières années
ils ont baissé tant tu t'en de produits
phytosanitaires
93 % des pesticides les plus
préoccupants ont été supprimés ils sont
mobilisés pour aller plus loin a
continué de réduire par toi ô partout
nous le pouvons produits phytosanitaires
pesticides et autres et ils continueront
pas par l'injonction mais par
l'investissement
mais je veux ici
en parlant devant la méditerranée vous
dire que nos paysans auront un rôle
extraordinaire à jouer dans les années
qui viennent
pour produire et protéger en même temps
car on ne protégera pas en produisant
moins
parce que parce que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à quelques milliers de
kilomètres de nous on l'ukraine n'est
pas simplement l'horreur de la guerre le
drame humanitaire que vivent nos frères
européens
le drame humanitaire et les réfugiés qui
arrivent aujourd'hui en europe et je
salue une fois encore la solidarité mart
et marseillaise
et les familles ici accueilli et protégé
encore sur le port ici ces derniers
jours
c'est un drame alimentaire qui se joue
un drame alimentaire
au proche et moyen-orient
en afrique du nord partout sur le
continent africain
aujourd'hui dans un an dans 18 mois il
manquait il manquera des céréales et
tente tant de ce qu'il faut pour nourrir
l'europe sera ce continent qui devra
continuer de produire pour aussi
alimenté
chaque rive de la méditerranée
et donc oui nous pourrons le faire grâce
à l'initiative que nous avons lancée et
par la troisième révolution agricole qui
passera par le numérique l'agro
robotique la génétique et le biocontrôle
nous le ferons car nous le pouvons
[Applaudissements]
notre jeunesse aura aussi sa part notre
jeunesse aura à se former dans les
métiers de l'énergie
de la batterie de l'industrie verte
nous formerons quatre cent mille
personnes en plus aux métiers de sens
que sont les métiers de la transition
écologique
métiers de l'énergie métiers de
l'industrie
métiers du recyclage et de la réparation
on va le faire
[Applaudissements]
notre jeunesse sera intégré au haut
conseil pour le climat à travers les
grandes associations
[Applaudissements]
notre jeunesse
par le service civique écologique pourra
participer au grand chantier de la
nation ces chantiers pour lutter et pour
dépolluer contre les grandes décharges
pour dépolluer nos rivières pour agir
dans nos forêts et partout sur nos
rivages nous le fond
[Applaudissements]
et pour susciter cette mobilisation
générale de la nation pour
l'environnement je propose que nous
organisions chaque année un grand moment
autour de nos jardins de nos paysages de
l'environnement et de notre planète
cette fête de la nature comme nous avons
su le faire une fête de la musique
pourrait se tenir au printemps par
exemple le quatrième samedi 2 mai
ce sera un grand moment d'union
nationale rassemblant collective et
collectivités locales associations
écoles agriculteurs
citoyens amoureux de la nature
pour agir et si vous voulez
elle serait un moment d'union nationale
autour de nos paysages de notre art de
vivre
de la protection de notre environnement
elle serait le signal envoyé au monde
que la france qui face à la question
sociale avait inventé l'état providence
ambitionne aujourd'hui de devenir la
grande nation écologique
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est en changeant le paradigme
politique
écologique économique pour nos paysages
pour nos vies
que nous pourrons ensemble
être celles et ceux qui savaient et
qu'ils ont fait car c'est le rôle de
notre génération
et c'est le défi qu avec vous je veux
relever
[Applaudissements]
mes amis
c'est en allant à la mer que le fleuve
reste fidèle à sa source disait jaurès
et je le dis ici devant notre
méditerranée
ce que nous avons à devenir
n'ai pas la nostalgie de ce que nous
avons été ni même exactement ce que nous
sommes
ce que nous avons à devenir
c'est de ne rien oublier de ce qu'il
nous a fait de la dignité du respect de
chacun qui nous constitue de la force de
ce république
de tous ses confluents qui forment la
france mais d'aller vers un cap nouveau
qui est un cap de respect de dignité de
diversité et d'écologie
[Applaudissements]
parce que oui
parce que oui le projet que nous portons
est un projet d'humanisme qui croient
dans l'économie l'innovation la culture
l'éducation la santé et l'humanisme du
21e siècle croix dans l'homme mais avec
l'homme dans la nature et le vivant car
ils sont indissociables
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi
le choix du 24 avril est aussi un choix
de civilisation
et je le dis
à tous nos compatriotes qui aujourd'hui
is it se sont abstenus vous n'était pas
un nos côtés
le choix est clair aujourd'hui
l'extrême droite est un projet climato
sceptiques un projet qui veut sortir des
ambitions actuelles de l'europe du
climat qui veut détruire les éoliennes
l'un des seuls projets de cette campagne
qui n'y croient pas lou nous y croyons
et nous ne le sommes
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi
le choix qui est devant nous vous l'avez
compris n'est pas simplement le choix
d'un président de la république c'est
bien un choix de civilisation
bâtir un avenir en commun ou le mettre
en péril
rester fidèles à ce que nous sommes au
rompre avec nos principes
[Applaudissements]
je compte sur chacun de nos compatriotes
sur chacun d'entre vous
le 24 avril prochain
ne cédez pas à la peur or à quoi bon
ne cédez pas aux au grand relativisme
qui consisterait à dire tout se vaut
celui qu'on aime pas forcément mais qui
est encore en marche
et l'extrême droite
parce qu'on vous a farsi la tête que
c'était la même chose non ce n'est pas
la même chose
[Applaudissements]
hahaha
et ça je ne l'accepterai pas parce que
le combat que je mène
et depuis le début de combat contre eux
contre l'exclusion et leurs idées et
cette haine contre les mensonges du
peuple
alors je dis aussi à tous ceux qui sont
en colère à tous ceux qui n'ont pas été
votées à tous ceux qui refusent leur dos
des choses et qui parfois de ma compagne
pas je les respecte chacune et chacun
mais je le dis en citant
je le dis en citant un autre grand
penseur de cette méditerranée
il est aussi des refus qui ne doivent
pas être des renoncements ne renoncez
pas et si vous ne voulez pas renoncer à
l'humanisme si vous ne voulez pas
renoncer à cette civilisation du 21e
siècle si vous ne voulez pas renoncé à
bâtir une grande nation écologique alors
rejoignez nous
non
le 24 avr elle
c'est un référendum pour ou contre
l'union européenne
[Applaudissements]
le 24 avril
c'est un référendum
pour ou contre l'écologie
[Applaudissements]
le 24 avril c'est un référendum pour ou
contre notre jeunesse
contre notre république et cette
nouvelle époque
oui le 24 avril
peut-être le point de départ d'une
nouvelle époque françaises et
européennes celle de l'espérance
celle du climat celle de la version
wii
nous gagnons
alors ce sera à nous de faire autrement
encore tous ensemble
vive marché vive la république et vive
la france
[Applaudissements]
bougies
comment
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour ce discours du président
macron le candidat en marche et
l'extrême droite non ce n'est pas la
même chose on a entendu la marseillaise
on entend l'hymne européen me
semble-t-il et on va l'écouter ensemble
sur figaro live
non
on
hélas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
près d'une heure et demie de discours
1h25 très précisément un discours
découpé en deux parties une première
partie d'une vingtaine de minutes sur
tout ce qui différencie emmanuel macron
de marine le pen avec cet emploi
régulier du mau extrême droite et puis
ensuite plus d'une heure plus d'une
heure consacré à l'écologie on va
débriefer tout ça on va se rendre sur
place pour avoir les premières
impressions des militants des
journalistes des cadres qui étaient à
marseille pour ce premier et seul
meeting d'entre deux tour d'emmanuel
macron on reste encore un peu à
marseille on écoute ce qui se passe
ensuite le président macron qui s'offre
un bain de foule après son heure et
demie de discours dans la cité phocéenne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
figaro la ville donc 17 heures presque
17 heures on a suivi ensemble pendant
presque une heure et demie le discours
d' emmanuel macron largement consacré à
l'écologie on va y revenir on va
développer évidemment tout ce qui s'est
dit avec avec des mesures importantes
annoncées reprises notamment à jean luc
mélenchon c'est ce qu'ils étaient c'est
ce qui était annoncé on savait que le
président macron le président-candidat
ferait un discours à destination de la
gauche pour récupérer ses voix de
jean-luc mélenchon qui compteront
évidemment lors du deuxième tour
dimanche dimanche 24 avril face à marine
le pen mais avant ça on va sur place on
retrouve vincent rosereau vincent vous
êtes vous êtes avec une militante c'est
bien ça comment cette militante a vécu
ce dixième des manuels macron
oui exactement tivo chèque une militante
qui est avec moi en ce moment qui a qui
a suivi ce discours comment vous avez
trouvé ce discours de d'emmanuel macro
alors égal à lui-même engagé avec l'
envie d'aller plus loin vous avez été
convaincu tout à fait
pour vous là c'était important de venir
ici pour pau pour montrer qu'il avait du
monde pour ce pour ce discours on se
doit d'être derrière lui si on veut
vraiment accompagner le changement oui
est ce que vous vous êtes vous pensez
que l'accueil que lui que la menace
marine le pen et est présente et qu'il
faut de fa du coup vraiment se mobiliser
alors oui il y aura toujours une menace
même si je suis convaincu qu'ils restent
quand même une part de protestation qui
est manifestée au cours du premier tour
mais on ne doit pas la négliger il faut
être d'autant plus vigilant est d'autant
plus présent aujourd'hui c'était
beaucoup axé sur l'écologie pour vous
c'est aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est un
vrai candidat écologique pour vous
évader le bas coûts est un vrai candidat
écologiste ah oui oui alors on lui a
reproché de ne pas assez lettre au
premier mandat mais il a eu le vrai je
pense que ça a été un peu occultés très
bien merci beaucoup
voilà tivo de ce que pouvait dire cette
militante qui était en direct de
marseille on va vous laisser avec les
images des wagons qu'ils continuent de
partir un peu plus loin derrière moi
vous prête j'ai essayé de vous
rapprocher de vous montrer ça
général ce que vous avez vu ce que vous
avez ressenti quelle ambiance on
s'attendait à un peu plus de monde
peut-être on nous dit 3000 personnes
raconté mans il a fait chaud les gens
partent et un peu en cours de meetings
expliqué -
[Musique]
oui effectivement en fait il faisait
assez chaud donc trois personnes a
annoncé alors autour de la de la scène
sur les images du candidat comme vous
l'avez vu la scène et est assez bon des
mes parents tenaient qu'on s'écarte et
un peu le tout l'espace n'était pas pris
non je vais vous montrer en fait voilà à
partir de cet endroit là en fait abonnés
de ce moment là il y avait de la foule
mais tous derrière et beaucoup moi non
beaucoup beaucoup moins de gens et est
en fait voilà il y avait dû couper
des gens des gens qu'on voyait pour
voiliers qui n'était - qui a été moins
présent en tout cas voilà beaucoup moins
que de 3000 personnes présentes mais
effectivement c'est peut-être dû aussi à
la chaleur on a d'ailleurs vu quelques
malaises qui ont eu lieu et les pompiers
qui ont dû intervenir
merci pour ces précisions on espère que
ces gens vont bien quand même vincent
bon reste du monde avec ces images des
manuels macron qui quittent qui quittent
cette scène de 2 mars et résumons ce qui
s'est dit ce qui s'est passé pendant
presque une heure vingt premières
minutes où on a vu un emmanuel macron
parler de marseille cette ville
cosmopolite avec ce projet humain
marseille en grand qu'il est venu
présenter au mois de septembre avec un
axe fort sur le sport la culture
l'éducation tout ça selon lui c'est ce
qui peut faire barrage ce qui le
différencie de de l'extrême droite il a
utilisé cette phrase nous sommes fait
deux millénaires de migration on avait
parlé d' ouverture en très très grande
partie et puis ensuite il a parlé de ses
échecs l'extrême droite se nourrit de
nos échecs je suis lucide mais je ne
suis pas là pour 50 plus je suis là pour
cinq ans de renouvellement en rappelant
qu'il n'était pas le camp du système
mais bel et bien de la de la rupture en
réponse peut-être à ce qu'a dit ce matin
marine le pen en eure-et-loir marine le
pen qui disait que le système
s'inquiéter
de l'arrivée de marine le pen au pouvoir
puisque de nombreuses tribunes de
nouveaux appels au vote en faveur d'
emmanuel macron étaient prononcées
depuis une semaine et puis il a aussi
prononcé cette phrase choisissez vos
ennemis ne confondez pas tout voilà
cette importante il a aussi qualifié
lister les excès selon lui de marine le
pen anti environnement anti liberté de
la presse anti europe est hantée
complotistes c'est ce qui l'a
sous-entendu notamment et puis après il
s'est penché assez largement sur sur
l'environnement on va en parler je vous
explique tout ça mais d'abord on vient
peu en direct les images des manuels
macron qui prend un bain de foule à
marseille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la barre de foule pour emmanuel macron a
l'impression que c'est assez violent on
a vu nombreuses reprises les membres du
j'espère la protection du président
intervenir pour essayer de faire avancer
le candidat président emmanuel macron
avec et bien un cadre un cadre un peu
similaire en tout cas avec cet hexagone
cette scène en hexagone comme a comme à
nanterre lors du premier meeting de
campagne avant avant le premier tour on
l'a vu on l'a lu proche des gens avec
assez assez peu de monde finalement à un
meeting à plus petite échelle que ce
qu'on pouvait imaginer un président en
bras de chemise pas de veste peut-être
pour montrer qu'il faisait chaud ça
donne un côté positif et puis pour
montrer aussi sans doute qu'il est au
travail qu'ils restent au travail il a
répété à de très nombreuses reprises la
date 24 avril 24 avril 24 avril la date
du second tour de la présidentielle et
puis à noter qu'il n'a jamais prononcé
non plus le nom de marine le pen jamais
la qualifier la candidate d'extrême
droite à de nombreuses reprises mais n'a
pas prononcé son nom j'en viens donc à à
ce qu'il a ce qu'il nous a dit ah mais
j'ai un petit message dans l'oreillette
g20 sans rose rond qui est avec un
militant vincent cats ont pensé de ce
meeting d'emmanuel macron
oui je suis avec un militant adria qui
est qui est venu ici adrien cas qu'avez
vous pensé de ce meeting emmanuel macron
et base c'était mon premier meeting donc
j'ai adoré franchement c'est top je suis
nouveau à marseille et j'étais très
content de pouvoir y participer
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois que
vous assistiez à un meeting politique
ouais ouais et vous avez été convaincu
sur subvention sur ce thème de
l'écologie dont il a beaucoup parlé vous
ça vous a beaucoup parlé bah moi ça
m'intéresse beaucoup donc ouais ça c'est
vraiment m un point important et je
pense que c'est le point sur lequel ça
va jouer vous aviez voté pour lui au
premier tour j'ai pas pu voter au
premier tour donc je n'avais pas pu être
souple pour raisons personnelles mais je
compte bien voter au deuxième et du coup
c'était l'occasion aussi pour me faire
un avis est ce que vous êtes est-ce que
d'être confiants aujourd'hui face à
marine le pen pour uma les maquereaux
oui franchement très bien merci beaucoup
adria
voilà pour ce que disait ce militant
alors qu emmanuel macron vient de partir
vous le voyez un peu plus loin
derrière moi on va essayer de trouver
quelques cadres du parti qui devraient
être présents d'ici d'ici quelques temps
de mon côté et je vous laisse la main
thibault
de meetings d'emmanuel macron résumons
ce qu'il a pu dire sur l'environnement
ça a duré presque presque une heure avec
ce qu'il a qualifié de messages
écologiques au premier tour il
caractérise ainsi le vote pour pour jean
luc mélenchon évidemment et il a listé
d'abord tous les projets réalisés ne pas
oublier ce que nous avons fait a dit
emmanuel macron la liste des projets
arrêtés avec notamment l'aéroport de
notre dame des landes qui là qu'il a mis
en avant il en a cité plusieurs autres
également un long rappel des actions
écolo ddd cinq ans à petite échelle
d'abord en france et puis aussi au
niveau international il a voulu se
montrer comme le meneur écologique au
niveau international au niveau mondial
et puis c'est aussi projeter sur
l'avenir aller deux fois plus vite sans
culpabiliser la répéta très nombreuses
reprises en prenant l'exemple des
agriculteurs par exemple qu'on essayait
de stigmatiser sur l'utilisation des
pesticides notamment il a aussi marqué
là à ce moment là son désaccord avec
avec marine le pen qui là c'était comme
climato-sceptiques anti écolo est
incompétente la politique sera
écologique ou ne sera pas et une annonce
principale qu'on essaiera de détails et
on essaiera de demander aux gens aux
cadres présents sur place aux ministres
notamment ce qu'il a voulu dire il a
annoncé que le premier ministre serait
en charge de l'écologie accompagné de
deux ministres un astre de la
planification énergétique pour faire de
la france la première nation sans gaz
sans pétrole et sans charbon voilà pour
le programme avec donc pour ce ministre
de la planification énergétique comme
objectif la sobriété énergétique un
grand plan des énergies renouvelables un
plan nucléaire six réacteurs qui seront
qui seront lancés il ya dix je choisis
le nucléaire par rapport au gaz et au
charbon et puis une stratégie de
l'hydrogène ça c'est pour le premier
ministre qui accompagnerait le le
premier ministre en place ce premier
ministre alors probablement écolo et
puis une deuxième une deuxième tête la
planification écologique territoriales
pour amener l'écologie dans les
territoires pour l'amener aussi amener
les transports en commun écolo partout
dans les régions et puis faire du
logement aussi une priorité sur sur
l'écologie mais aussi précisé qu'il ne
voulait pas tourner le dos à l'économie
on comprend bien ici que c'est une
économie une écologie sens en
décroissance voilà ce qu'a voulu
préciser emmanuel macron avec aussi un
point sur l'éducation aux enfants de la
maternelle à l'université on a compris
qu'il y aurait peut-être des classes des
cours d'écologie nous verrons nous
demanderons aussi des précisions pour
président et à l'entourage du président
candidat et puis aussi parlé d'une
journée de la nature à l'image d'une une
journée de la musique d'une fête de la
musique une journée de la nature du
d'union nationale voilà il a bien
détaillé ce grand plan la grande nation
écologique et il a précisé lui aussi de
manière différente de marine le pen que
le 24 avril serait un choix de
civilisation une civilisation écologique
voilà ce que ce que dit
emmanuel macron voilà pour pour ses
annonces sur l'écologie c'était un
meeting largement axé sur sur cette
question vincent je reviens vers vous je
vois que vous déambulez dans les âmes
dans les allées du meeting je sais que
vous cherchez des des têtes d'affiché
pour pouvoir répondre à nos questions
mais je reviens quand même vers vous
vous avez senti cette teneur sa tournure
écologique dans ce discours
oui effectivement on s'y attendait ça a
été le cas finalement c'était un
discours très basé sur les sur
l'écologie comme vous l'aviez dit à un
début de meeting plutôt basé sur son
opposition à marine le pen puis une
large large partie consacrée a consacré
à l'écologie puisque il essaye aussi de
faire venir à lui des électeurs plein de
gens de jean luc mélenchon par exemple
quand il parle de planification
écologique que lui on parle aussi c'est
aussi de ceux de ce côté là là vous
voyez peut-être pas sur mes images mais
voilà il est porte qui était de devant
sont fermés maintenant le président est
rentré dans ce bâtiment et les militants
ont commencé à partir petit à petit et
je vais essayer de vous trouver
effectivement un cadre un cadre du parti
dès que je retrouve
[Musique]
l'un vers vont les écoutes pour savoir
ce qu'ils ont pensé pour savoir s'ils
sont inquiet aussi pour pour le second
tour résumons-nous 1h20 1h25 précisément
de discours d' emmanuel macron à
marseille pour son seul et unique
discours d'entre deux tours seul et
unique meeting d'entre deux tours a
marseille une ville qui lui est cher ou
jean luc mélenchon a réalisé le meilleur
score dans ce premier tour avec plus de
2 31% des suffrages contre 22 pour
emmanuel macron il ya des voies aller
chercher c'est le trésor de guerre
évidemment cet électorat de jean luc
mélenchon au premier tour et on a eu
pendant presqu'une heure et demie un
discours résume résolument à gauche un
très clairement avec avec d'abord un
rappel sur ses valeurs humanistes sur le
côté cosmopolite de la ville de
marseille et ce grand projet humain qui
est marseille en grand et puis après une
grande partie sur l'écologie principaux
commandants de ce discours on essaye de
vivre un peu ces images on a essayé
d'écouter ce qui se passe à marseille
pour entendre les réactions des
différents des différents militants des
différentes personnes qui sont venues
assister à ce discours on parle de 3000
personnes tiens vincent rosereau vous
êtes avec quelqu'un
oui thibault je sais pas si vous m'avez
entendu
je suis avec eux
je suis avec une militante effective
effectivement j'ai avec une militante
qui s'appelle qui s'appelle corinne et
qui est qui et qui est venu aujourd'hui
pour pour ce meeting comment vous avez
trouvé le meeting emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui mais j'ai trouvé excellent
parce qu'en fait il a il a répondu à
certains mais question devance sur le
sur le programme qui étaient toutes les
parties écologie parce que je suis très
impliqué en environnement donc
évidemment que toute cette démonstration
est ce et ce cheminement mon forcément
convaincu encore un peu plus est ce que
vous êtes aujourd'hui voilà vous a
convaincu sur sur cette partie là par
rapport à d'autres candidats ps vous
avez voté pour lui au premier tour déjà
ce virage on peut peut-être parler d'un
virage écologique même s'il en parle de
clairement c'est quelque chose qui veut
qu'il vous plaît j'imagine bien
évidemment puisque comme je vous dis je
suis président d'une association qui
s'occupent d'environnement
donc forcément c'est le sujet le plus
est le plus pertinent au mois dans cette
campagne et surtout dans ce meeting
aujourd'hui dans un peu plus d'une
semaine il y aura le il y aura le
deuxième tour face à marine le pen
emmanuel macron a voulu bien ce a voulu
bien se différencier d'elle est ce que
vous êtes confiante pour ce pur pour ce
deuxième tour je pense qu'on peut jamais
être confiant il faut attendre justement
le résultat des votes je peux comprendre
que des gens votent pour marine le pen
même si il décortique un peu le
programme il verrait qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses qui sont irréalisables donc je
pense que ce ce discours était justement
très réaliste très pragmatique et que
bien évidemment
mais on va attendre dimanche ce soir
avant de se prononcer mais on sait que
quand même dans la région marine le pen
devrait faire un très très gros scores
très bien merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous
merci à cette nuit temps d'avoir répondu
à vos questions vincent étonné je vous
donne un sondage qui vient de tomber une
petite demi-heure de ça le sondage ipsos
sopra steria qui donne emmanuel macron
vainqueur à 55 5% contre
44,5 forçant pour marine le pen voilà
pour pour ce pour ce sondage qui vient
de tomber évidemment ce n'est qu'un
sondage mais ça vous donne une
indication de la tendance actuelle avant
le débat qui sera le prochain grand
rendez-vous un débat qu'on suivra
évidemment en direct sur le figaro l'ice
et mercredi soir mercredi soir le pour
le grand débat d'entre deux tours entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen je vous
rappelle le programme de chacun d'abord
aujourd'hui marine le pen était ce matin
dans l'eure-et-loir et là elle a
expliqué que le système craignait son
arrivée et que c'est pour ça que des
artistes des sportifs de nombreux cadres
politiques avaient appelé à voter
emmanuel macron ce à quoi emmanuel
macron a répondu qu'il n'était pas le
camp du système qu'il était toujours le
camp de la rupture qu'il incarnait le
camp de la de la rupture voilà pour ce
qu'a répondu emmanuel macron qui était
donc en meeting et on l'a suivi ensemble
pendant presque une heure et demie à
marseille un meeting largement axé sur
l'écologie avec plusieurs propositions
phares on va y revenir dans un instant
avec nos journalistes sur place vincent
heureusement qu'il doit retrouver l'un
des journalistes qui écrit des papiers
qui suit emmanuel macron tous les jours
c'est cet arthur berda qui suit emmanuel
macron tout au long de sa campagne il
est très bien renseigné il va peut-être
pouvoir nous expliquer plusieurs de ces
mesures est donc dans les jours à venir
on aura ce grand débat qui aura lieu
mercredi soir marine le pen s'isolera de
l'ain à mercredi de lundi midi à
mercredi midi elle veut préparer ne pas
arriver fatigué lors de ce débat qu'elle
avait raté elle avait elle même avoué il
ya il ya cinq ans et elle veut elle veut
pouvoir parfaitement réussir ce débat
montrer qu'elle a progressé et qu'elle
est compétente sur toutes les questions
l'écologie on y reviendra probablement
ce sera l'un des thèmes de ce débat à
n'en pas douter puisque emmanuel macron
on a fait son son son meeting
aujourd'hui il en a fait sa priorité
notamment pour parler aux électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon je vous rappelle les
mesures cette mesure cette annonce
proposé par emmanuel macron avec un
premier ministre qui serait d'après ce
qu'on a compris le ministre de
l'ecologie entouré de deux autres
ministres un ministre de la
planification énergétique pour faire de
la france la première nation sans gaz
sans pétrole et sans charbon avec comme
objectif la sobriété énergétique
un grand plan des énergies renouvelables
un plan nucléaire il l'a aussi rappelé 1
avec 7 cette phrase entre le charbon et
le gaz je choisi clairement le nucléaire
il a bien pris son temps pour
l'expliquer emmanuel macron six
réacteurs devraient être mis en place si
emmanuel macron été réélu dans huit
jours la stratégie sur l'hydrogène
également et puis un deuxième ministre
auprès du premier ministre lui qui s'est
occupé de la qui s'occuperait de la
planification écologique territoriales
pour amener l'écologie dans les
territoires les transports en commun
écolo des logements également beaucoup
plus écologique le tout sans tourner le
dos à l'économie pas de décroissance on
l'a bien compris il veut faire de
l'écologie l'un des vecteurs d'économies
dans l'est dans les années à venir
emmanuel macron pour faire de la france
la grande nation écologique il a répété
que c'était un choix de civilisation la
civilisation
écolo vous avez toujours ces images en
direct de marseille on a vu emmanuel
macron quitter lé il ya de cela dix
petites minutes cette jardins du pharo
sur les hauteurs de marseille une ville
tout à fait symbolique il l'a répété à
de nombreuses reprises lui le supporters
de marseille est une ville qui lui tient
particulièrement à coeur on a vu auprès
de lui des anciens
cadres de la droite dans le sud on a vu
notamment christian estrosi on a vu
renaud muselier on a vu martine vassal
la présidente de la métropole aix
marseille voilà pour les gens qui
l'entouraient on a aussi vu joël giraud
le ministre des territoires on a vu
julien de normandie le ministre de
l'agriculture qui répondait d'ailleurs
allocation au début de ce live avant le
discours d' emmanuel macron vincent
rosereau vous êtes sur place
racontez-nous qu'est ce qui se passe à
ce qu emmanuel macron quel est son
programme est ce qu'on en sait un peu
plus sur ce qui se passe maintenant pour
le président candidat
alors je sais pas d'arroser votre
question juste quelqu'un qui vient de
passer avec un mégaphone et du coup je
n'entends pas très bien ce qui se passe
mais ce qui est là les gens sont en
train de 200 trains de
jeu alors que le maître avec je vais
être avec arthur berda en direct arthur
behrakis qui suit le président macron au
quotidien pour le figaro arthur qu'avez
vous pensé de son dos au meeting des
manuels macron eh bien c'était un
meeting à dresser quasi exclusivement à
la gauche emmanuel macron cite
d'ailleurs à deux reprises l'avenir en
commun qui est le nom du livre et
programmatique de jean luc mélenchon a
peut être reculé en même temps avec eux
non sérieusement menacé par le cas les
équipes des manuels mâcon sont en train
d'évacuer un petit peu les les militants
les sympathisants présents pour ne
laisser que
doc et
emmanuel macron site à deux reprises cet
avenir en commun qu'il veut bâtir avec
les français dit-il l'avenir en commun
c'est bien sûr le nom du livre et
programmatique de jean luc mélenchon
donc le message est clair il est adressé
à la gauche aux insoumis jean luc
mélenchon qui est arrivé en tête dans la
cité phocéenne au premier tour de la
présidentielle avec plus de 30 % des
voix il distance emmanuel macron d'un
peu plus de 9 points emmanuel macron
était deuxième donc l'objectif
d'aujourd'hui c'était s'adresser aux
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon est axé
son discours sur l'écologie emmanuel
macron fait de l'écologie un petit peu
le coeur du nouveau paradigme politique
dit il novices seront écologiques ou ne
seront pas l'économie sera écologique ou
ne sera pas emmanuel mâcon s'adresse
donc aux électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
en accent très fort sur l'écologie son
premier ministre son futur prochain
premier ministre homme ou femme sera
d'ailleurs en charge de la planification
écologique deux ministres seront nous
doter d'un nouveau portefeuille qui
n'existaient pas jusqu'ici la
planification énergétique pour rien et
la planification écologique
territoriales pour l'autre donc un
discours adressé aux électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon si on ne l'a pas
suffisamment 10 et un discours dont le
but est d'essayer un petit peu de
récupérer le vote écolo et donc on
imagine d'accès sont d'éventuels second
prochain et dernier quinquennat sur
cette thématique de l'écologie alors les
questions des internautes sur est ce que
le ministre de l'écologie en tant que
tel va disparaître ou est ce qu'il sera
remplacé par ce prix me stresser
différents ministères et bien c'est une
excellente question que posent les
internautes du figaro emmanuel macron de
l'apathie d'abord donc c'est la question
reste ouverte il faudra d'ailleurs là
lui poser ou en tout cas à la pause et à
son entourage ce qui est certain c'est
que le ministère de l'écologie en tant
que tel n'existe déjà pas à l'heure
actuelle on parle d'un mystère de la
transition écologique cette transition
elle doit devenir une planification dans
l'esprit des manuels mâcon et cette
planification elle doit être à la fois
écologique et énergétique et donc on
peut imaginer que non il n'y ait plus de
ministère de l'écologie comme c'est déjà
le cas même s'il reste un mystère de la
transition écologique installé à l'hôtel
de roquelaure aux invalides et donc un
espèce de grand ministère divisé en deux
ministres planification écologique
territoriale c'était important discours
d' emmanuel macron et planification
énergétique le tout étant rattachées non
plus un ministère de l'écologie qui
serait à l'hôtel de roquelaure mais
rattaché à matignon puisque le ou la
futur prochain premier ministre sera
chargé de cette planification écologique
on l'a bien compris l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est aussi deux sur tout s'adresser aux
électeurs devant lui mélenchon d'arrivée
les combats tout à fait aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit des proches des manuels macron
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon et
l'électorat écologiste au sens large du
terme ils représentent environ 30% des
voix se calculer le fond en ajoutant les
voix de jean luc mélenchon 21 ou 22 %
selon les résultats définitifs les voix
de yannick jadot un petit peu moins de
5% des voix et les voiles anne hidalgo à
peine plus de 1% mis bout à bout ça fait
selon lui un tiers de l'électorat et
donc oui c'est à eux qu'il faut
s'adresser l'électorat principal étant
celui de jean luc mélenchon mais la
thématique qui regroupe ses trois
électorale à estang l'écologie politique
très bien merci beaucoup à tout va la
d'avoir été avec nous pour débriefer ce
meeting des wagons j'ai une question
essayer de garder à arthur garde à un
instant s'il vous plaît vincent rose
rond j'ai une petite question pour lui
on a vu un meeting à à plus petite
échelle finalement que celui de
nanterre est ce que c'était prévu est ce
qu'on s'attendait à un si peu de monde
aujourd'hui on parle de 3000 personnes
qui attendaient exactement le camp
macron
oui alors alors je je me décale en même
temps parce qu'il ya les barrières qui
avance très petit couple avait pu le
voir pendant l'interview on va se
décaler on va se mettre dans un coin
comme ça on sera pas embêté pendant
pendant l'interview arthur on ne peut on
parler de du dispositif aujourd'hui on
attend des 3000 personnes il a semblé y
avoir moins on n'est pas sur le même
meeting que les uranais ya quelques
semaines tout à fait vous avez raison de
souligner que ce discours il y avait
d'abord ce qu'il fallait en retenir sur
le plan politique il ya également ce
qu'il faut en déduire sur le plan
politique ce qu'il faut en déduire ces
qu'emmanuel macron aujourd'hui n'a pas
réussi son pari de la mobilisation
ces équipes rêvées même à voix haute ce
matin d'environ 5000 personnes on en a
été très loin aujourd'hui il y avait au
pharo entre deux et trois mille
personnes à tout cas c'est un petit peu
plus de 3000 selon les équipes de
campagne d' emmanuel macron sans doute
moins en réalité la pelouse était un
petit peu clairsemée ce qui tombe bien
d'ailleurs c'était une pelouse verte
quand on veut parler d'écologie il est
mieux de ne pas l'abîmer or il n'y avait
pas suffisamment de monde pour abîmer la
pelouse aujourd'hui au pharo et donc oui
c'est un échec pour emmanuel macron en
termes de mobilisation puisque la jauge
et à aller 2000 3000 personnes grand
maximum on est très loin des plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes que
jean luc mélenchon avait d'ailleurs
réunis sur les plages du prado il y a
environ un mois très bien merci vos
couvertures vincent je garde arthur une
petite dernière seconde pour une toute
petite dernière question je sais qu'il
est un papier à écrire derrière mais on
veut savoir quel est le programme d'
emmanuel macron jusqu'au jusqu'au débat
d'entre deux tours parce qu'on sait
qu'ils mènent avec marine le pen va
s'isoler que l'algérie emmanuel macron
est-ce qu'il va continuer à se déplacer
jusqu'à mercredi soir est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus là dessus
alors je suis désolé mais effectivement
tu regardes a dû partir pour créer un
parti à l'instant et du coup je les ai
perdus dans la foule je ne pourrais pas
vous répondre à cette question je suis
désolé et en plus de ça on est en train
de se faire par les équipes pour partie
par
la cie vous on vous demande de ne partir
mon cher vincent c'est que il est
l'heure pour nous aussi de rendre de
rendre l'antenne merci de nous avoir
suivis merci de nous avoir accompagnés
vincent redon depuis depuis marseille
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sur ce
meeting d'une heure et demie d'emmanuel
macron le seul d'entre deux tours de la
présidentielle vous restez avec nous sur
le figaro là évidemment on suit toute
cette semaine politique vous ne raterez
pas le débat le débrief du débat d'entre
deux tours c'est mercredi soir vous ne
raterez évidemment pas la grande soirée
présidentielle le dimanche prochain avec
entre-temps un meeting de marine le pen
à arras elle aussi elle tiendra un
meeting dans cette dans cette deuxième
semaine et puis on se retrouve
évidemment très vite sur le figaro live
à bientôt